es ist soweit durch den anstieg des
meeresspiegels sind die pacific schon
jetzt mindestens acht ganze insel
verschwunden für immer der klimawandel
fordert seinen tribut was das für die
menschen dort bedeutet und wie die
zukunft für viele weitere hin werden
aber auch andere küstennahe gebiete
bedeutet jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
forschungsteams weltweit gehen
mittlerweile davon aus dass die ozeane
im globalen durchschnitt in jedem jahr
drei millimeter ansteigen
das klingt wenig ist aber erheblich fest
steht auch dass das nicht erst in
zukunft sondern bereits heutzutage die
menschheit bedroht und dieses schicksal
den inselbewohnern nicht nur ihr zuhause
sondern teilweise auch hinlegen nimmt
doch dass das erste land die ersten
inseln bereits komplett verschwunden
sind war bisher kaum bekannt und es
nimmt immer schlimmere ausmaße haben
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus australien berichten jetzt dass das
meer schon mindestens acht inseln im
pazifik vollständig verschluckt hat
eine absolute katastrophe schon im
vergangenen jahr hatte ein australisches
forschungsteam den untergang von fünf
inseln der salomonen einem inselstaat in
der südsee festgestellt dass aktuelle
forschungsergebnisse aus australien
sieht diese entwicklung auch für
mikronesien an inselstaat im westlichen
pazifischen ozean in beiden regionen
liegt der anstieg des meeresspiegels
weit über dem durchschnitt
dort wurden wir sogar an jährlicher
anstieg von 1,2 zentimetern gemessen
das klingt erst mal wenig hat aber
schlimme folgen drei der verschluckten
inseln hatten für die bevölkerung in
der region eine große historische
bedeutung so das forschungsteam
aber nicht nur das die bewohner
bewohnerinnen sind durch diese
entwicklung gezwungen alles aufzugeben
und entweder in höhere regionen
umzusiedeln
oder aber ihr leben an einem anderen ort
komplett neu anzufangen
und das ist die bittere realität ein
aktuelles projekt auf den kater red
inseln in papua neuguinea hat sich genau
das zur aufgabe gemacht die komplette
bevölkerung wird auf eine höher
gelegene insel etwa 90 kilometer
entfernt von der eigentlichen heimat
umgesiedelt eine wirklich traurige
entwicklung die menschen stehen vor
existenzbedrohenden fragen wie was
passiert mit uns und unserer heimat wo
können wir hin wie können wir
überleben was passiert mit unserer
kultur werden wir jetzt teil eines
anderen staates und werden wir dort
akzeptiert so wie wir sind das
forschungsteam aus australien hat auch
analysiert welche umweltbedingungen
inseln zumindest eine zeit lang vor dem
ansteigenden meeresspiegel schützen
dafür haben sie satelliten aufnahmen
analysiert und mit vielen insel
bewohnern gesprochen daraus leiten sie
ab dass beispielsweise mangrovenwälder
zumindest kurzzeitig einen gewissen
schutz bieten zb bei der insel die von
einem mangrovenwald umgeben ist und eine
vergleichsweise geringe küstenerosionen
aufweist auch inseln in er
windgeschützten westen leiden weniger
unter dem anstieg des meeresspiegels
dennoch sieht die zukunft für die
inseln im pazifischen ozean nicht gut
aus sechs weitere inseln dieser insel
ketten sind ebenfalls kurz davor vom
meer verschluckt zu werden so die
traurige bilanz des forschungsdienst
glück im unglück dass diese zumindest
ungewohnt sind und kein menschenleben
direkter gefahr ausgesetzt ist aber auch
anderen kleinen inselstaaten wie den
marshall inseln und den bewohnern der
malediven beispielsweise droht dieses
katastrophenszenario und die erosion der
küsten ist nur ein problem von vielen
dass mehr wasser vergiftet ja auch das
ackerland und nimmt den menschen ihre
nahrungsgrundlage an den betroffenen
orten wachsen oft nicht mal mehr
kokospalmen so salzig ist das
grundwasser nicht umsonst gibt es die so
genannte allianz kleiner inselstaaten
ein zusammenschluss von rund 40 inseln
und küsten nationen die in ihrer
existenz bedroht sind auch orte an denen
wir gerne urlaub machen sind dabei zum
beispiel die dominikanische republik
kuba die seychellen oder die
fidschi-inseln und wenn wir ehrlich sind
müssen genau diese region schon jetzt
oder aber in naher zukunft mit den
folgen zurecht kommen die staaten wie
china australien usa oder auch europa
durch ihren unglaublichen co2 ausstoß
zu verantworten haben denn das ist
sicher der anstieg des meeresspiegels
hängt mit der globalen erwärmung den
klimawandel zusammen und der es menschen
gemacht es gibt studien die
prognostizieren dass im jahr 2100 ein
fünftel der weltbevölkerung
klimaflüchtlinge sind überflutete
küstenregionen sorgen diesem szenario
nach für eine massenflucht ins
landesinnere in dem dann nutzbare
flächen viel zu knapp werden und das
alles hätten wir dann zu verantworten
wieder ein wichtiges argument dafür
dass es allerhöchste zeit ist endlich
unsere treibhaus emissionen einzudämmen
denn das ist wohl immer noch die beste
versicherung gegen den klimawandel und
den anstieg des meeresspiegels irakkrieg
so heiß ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein
video zum thema klima waren also auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit klimawandel
bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt
da geht es um die erdrückende beweise
für den menschengemachten klimawandel
es gibt keinen einzigen grund mehr zu
zweifeln in diesem sinne bis dann bleibt
da